hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host John
Carroll it's very natural when things go
wrong when when something is very
different than what you were led to
expect it would be to demand an
explanation to ask why is it like this
what is the reason why the explanation
for the State of Affairs that you didn't
expect but what does that mean exactly
does an explanation mean some causal
connection between one event or another
or is it a way that the world is if you
remember back when we talked to Judea
Pearl about cause and effect and pearl
of course is one of the world's experts
in teasing out what causes lead to what
effects in all sorts of messy situations
in the real world
he claimed that babies spend their time
making causal maps of the world saying
if I poke this it reacts in this other
way so what exactly is going on not just
in babies but in grown-ups also when we
human beings construct this image of the
world or this model of the world which
says this is an explanation for this
other thing over there well today's
guest is Tony lombroso she's one of the
world's experts in exactly this question
she's a psychologist at Princeton
University and her lab at Princeton is
called the concepts and cognition lab
which I love that as a name I would love
to work in the concepts and cognition
lab where she studies uh what an
explanation is what do we mean when we
say here's the explanation for that what
do we what should we mean what are we
talking about philosophically as well as
psychologically uh do people agree on
what explanations are good why do we
want them what what is it psychological
that moves us to burst into the room and
demand an explanation for something uh I
like it because it's a not only a
psychology topic but of course it has
something to do with the structure of
the world out there the fact that there
are things in the world that we accept
as explanations this is an interesting
fact all by itself and there's other
things that someone might say when you
demand an explanation which most of us
would go hmm no that doesn't really work
going down to very you know detailed
questions at their for example at the
intersection of Science and religion
when you say why is there something
rather than nothing and someone says
well God made it that way
is that a good explanation and does that
satisfy you should it satisfy you and
I'm not telling you what the answer is
I'm saying these are very good questions
we're going to get into it so let's go
[Music]
Dani lambroso welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me Sean so you
work on explanations which is something
that to me sounds like very natural for
a psychologist to work on yeah it's
always funny to me when I read
psychology papers and they say like this
is actually an understudied area of
psychology and I think that yours is one
is it true that explanation is an
understudied area of cognitive
psychology I I think it depends which
types of explanations you're thinking
about so two communities have thought
about explanation for a long time one is
social psychologists they've been really
interested in how we explain our own
behavior and other people's behavior and
there's Decades of research specifically
thinking about explanation in that
context and another Community that's
been really focused on explanation is
Educators people thinking about
educational psychology and learning and
explanation in those contexts I think
what's newer is people appreciating how
fundamental explanation might be to our
everyday cognitive lives not just just
in the social domain but more generally
so I and many other people as well I
think over the last I'd say two three
decades have really
um focused on new questions related to
explanation but drawing upon what we
know from social psychology
identification psychology and so but is
your work then in the in the domain of
cognitive psychology I consider myself a
cognitive psychologist although you know
as with any demarcations between
disciplines the boundaries get a little
bit fuzzy and I right I think they
should not be very well sharply drawn I
think what's most distinctive about the
approach that I've taken to thinking
about explanation is that many of the
questions I'm interested in are the ones
that arise in the context of philosophy
yourself right so philosophers of
science have an interested in
explanation for a very long time
overwhelmingly thinking about the rule
of explanation and science but not
exclusively and I think if if you take
seriously the idea that there is some
important connections between everyday
human cognition and what we do as
everyday reasons trying to make sense of
the world and what scientists are doing
in their quest to make sense of the
world then it's very natural to think
that the kinds of questions that arise
about explanation in the context of
science that philosophers of science
have been interested in also have
analogs in the context of just everyday
human cognition I did want to ask you
about that because I I can imagine the
philosophers want to know what
explanation is and you know what's a
good explanation whatever whereas I
might imagine that psychologists are
also interested in How We Do
explanations how we start doing
explanations as children and things like
that so do you see quite a bit of
overlap and intersection there I think
that's right so I think philosophers
have asked largely what explanation is
and also what explanations should be so
asking a more normative question I think
those questions are also relevant for
psychology but on top of that we might
want to think about where explanations
come from developmentally but also one
of the things that I've asked a lot in
my own work is what do explanations do
and I think that might be a more useful
entry point for starting to think about
this right so rather than first defining
what an explanation is and then maybe
thinking about its consequences we can
ask what do explanations do for us why
are we the sorts of creatures to explain
right what's the function of this
activity and perhaps by getting a grip
on that on the role of explanation on
what explanation do we can then work
backwards to thinking about what
explanations are right so rather than
starting from a definition sort of
starting from a functional role what
explanations do and as if I recall
correctly
um there's even the possibility that
much is in physics you could get
feedback from the science end into the
philosophy and I think that in one of
your papers you're saying that this
philosopher made the following claims
about our intuitions about explanations
so we tested them and it turns out those
are not our intuitions yeah that's right
and we've done that across a variety of
projects and sometimes we find that our
results Accord very closely to what
philosophers have said and sometimes we
find interesting departures and of
course whenever that happens there's an
interesting question is it just that
humans are wrong or the philosophers
I think it varies Case by case do the
philosophers then listen are they are
they uh do you is it an active in
practice uh back and forth between your
work and those of the philosophers
that's an interesting question I think
it it really varies by what question and
philosophers are asking and of course
switch philosophers there's a huge
variability in the field as I'm sure you
know better than I do in the extent to
which people engage with empirical work
of various kinds in in philosophical
work but I think I think it does vary um
I can give you an example if you'd like
in a case where I think there is
interesting crosstalk back and forth so
one uh one area where the stemologists
in particular have been really
interested in explanation is in the
context of what's called inference the
best explanation and this is something
that I think most people kind of
intuitively are familiar with you know
Sherlock Holmes claimed that he engaged
in deduction but a lot of the time when
he was students really inference the
best explanation he was looking at a
bunch of evidence and trying to come up
with what would best explain that body
of evidence and on the basis of that
concluding that that explanation might
be true so that's a pattern of inference
that we see in science but we see all
the time in just everyday cognition
and one question might be you know what
when ought we to engage in this kind of
reasoning right is it ever normatively
warranted is it a good kind of reasoning
uh or is it a mistake
um and I think there's truth to both of
those things there's conditions under
which it's good and conditions under
which it's bad but there's an
interesting dialogue that's happened
back and forth between some of the
empirical evidence and some of the kinds
of normative claims that epistemologist
might make that have to do with thinking
about what the goals of that kind of
inference might be so you might think
our goal in
um engaging in certain kinds of
inference like things like this might
just be to be like as accurate as
possible meaning that we want to sort of
like minimize our long-term inaccuracy
we just want to like in the long run get
things right and we want to have
practices for updating our beliefs that
mean that we're going in the long range
uh be at least raw and if you have that
view you might think that what we ought
to do is something like plywood's called
Bayes Rule raise an inference from
statistics it's sort of a rule that
tells us how to combine our prior
beliefs with the evidence we have in
order to arrive at what they call a
posterior probability now it turns out
that if you look at human explanation
evaluation and so on and these processes
have inference the best explanation
there's some systematic departures from
what Bayes rule tells us that we should
do no
um yeah I know I know I'm sorry I'm
sorry to be the bearer of bad news for
somebody who wants to Advocate
um
but um and I'm happy to say more about
what those look like but the interesting
thing is you know so philosophers could
just say well I guess you know lay
people are just wrong about this they're
doing it poorly but I think a really
interesting idea that's that's been
proposed is maybe maybe the thing humans
are trying to optimize isn't long-term
inaccuracy maybe it's something else
um so what might that something else be
what might something that as I guess as
just what I was going to ask uh you know
human beings evolve under Evolution
natural selection you know reproductive
Fitness and things like that so in some
sense the answer is always reproductive
Fitness right but I could imagine that
having an accurate uh and predictive
model of reality helps with my
reproductive Fitness right yeah that's
right um so the one of the proposals and
there's a handful of people who've
argued for this under the brand or sort
of explanationism is that maybe what we
want to do is get things mostly right in
the short term rather than being
released wrong in the long term and
that's something that I think you can
imagine trying to motivate in terms of
reproductive Fitness yeah right we don't
we don't know if we're going to be
around long term but if we can get
things mostly right in the short term
that might be that might be the standard
that actually matters and it turns out
that if that's what you're going for you
shouldn't always use space roll
sometimes you should do something a
little bit different
um you might also think that what we
ought to do depends on our cognitive
limitations as humans right if we just
don't have the the cognitive capacities
that allow us to engage in certain kinds
of statistical inferences or very
complicated kinds of mental computations
you might think that we ought to employ
the kinds of shortcuts that are going to
be good enough given the cognitive
Machinery that we have and so that's
another idea that I think again makes
sense within an evolutionary context but
gives us goals for what we're trying to
do that look a little bit different from
for example just applying Bayesian
inference yeah I mean thinking and being
cognitively careful both takes a lot of
energy and a lot of space I guess a lot
of neurons but also time and maybe you
don't have time when the lion is bearing
down on you to think too hard about what
to do next that that's right that's
right and so being fast being efficient
having sort of heuristics or mental
shortcuts arriving at conclusions might
be very beneficial and that's some of
what we see in terms of the explanations
we prefer right so for example one of
the things that we looked at in my lab
is people's preference for simpler
explanations and you might imagine
simpler explanations are easier to
process easier to remember easier to
arrive at and so on and so you might see
a host of these benefits so I was going
to ask and maybe that's the answer what
what are the systematic deviations from
sort of perfect Bayesian reasoning that
we might expect in real human being
right so there's been a handful and I'll
tell you just a couple for which we have
the most evidence
um so one of them is that there is some
evidence that people
seem to be more sensitive
to the evidence that they ought to
compared to Bayesian inference meaning
that they will converge to an
explanation that fits the data well more
that you know more quickly than they
should and consistent with this idea
that they're trying to get to the it's
probably right fast interesting okay in
my own lab one of the things that we
have looked at as I mentioned is
Simplicity and the way we've we've tried
to get at that in Psychology experiments
is by giving people scenarios where
there's uh one or a couple of effects
that they observe and they're trying to
come up with the best causal
explanations if they're trying to come
up with an explanation that cites one or
more causes that generate those effects
and under those conditions if you know
the probability of the causes and you
know the probability of the effects
given the causes you could just do the
math and so in some sense we kind of
have the the ground Truth For What the
right pattern of reasoning would be if
people were just doing it was most
likely but what we find is that although
people are very sensitive to the
probabilistic evidence they choose
simpler explanations more often than
they should where we Define simpler
explanations as those that involve fewer
causes that are themselves Linux so you
know for example if you have two
symptoms that you can explain by appeal
to one disease or by appeal to two
diseases that each just cause One
symptom you find that people prefer the
single disease explanation more often
than they ought to given the
probabilistic evidence that they have
physicists certainly act that way but
maybe it works in physics in a way that
might not work in medicine or everyday
life yeah it's an interesting idea I you
know in our in our lab cases we want to
know what the ground truth is right so
we set things up so that we we have some
basis for saying what the what's most
likely or what's not
um but in most real world cases we don't
have the ability to cleanly say when
people are getting things right and when
they're getting things wrong and so what
we could be seeing in the lab is the
over generalization of a strategy that
actually maybe does make a lot of sense
in a lot of real world cases I mean in
the physics cases and I'd be curious if
you have a I thought I know our
physicists right to be doing this are
they wrong to be doing this has it
helped scientific practice and
theorizing for them to show a preference
for explanations that have this kind of
structure I think it is a big ongoing
debate to be perfectly honest especially
in in my little corner of fundamental
physics where progress is a little
stalled these days and so people are
debating different methodologies based
on their personal preferences right and
you know some like like I have a
strategy which is to step back and think
about the foundations in a more
philosophical way to make sure that you
know we're on a firm ground where we
where we do our uh further down the road
reasoning other people are just gonna
like switch fields and you know come to
some area where they can come up with a
better explanation test against the data
and others are going to argue about
beauty and math and all these things so
I I that's why I was asking you I really
it's uh physicists love what works right
and when some strategy works for one
problem they declare Victory but the
next problem is always different it so
we don't know yeah yeah and I think the
everyday cognition cases are hard if I
had to guess I would say that
um there are many cases where preference
for explanations with a structure in
fact does lead a sister right synthetic
assets I think it's very hard to
quantify that in in everyday cases well
as a psychologist is there is there an
understanding of psychologically why we
are driven to seek explanations
um you know is there is it just that
there's a part of a human brain that is
naturally curious or uh which sounds
kind of lofty almost like we're
naturally curious creatures or is it is
it more down to earth do you think so we
definitely have evidence that basically
from from the moment kids have the
language capacities to ask questions
they are asking questions and a lot of
those questions are what I would call
explanation seeking questions
um so it seems like it's it's it's an
early emerging human capacity and we
know it plays an important role in human
learning so what what I've argued in
some of my work and I think other people
have argued for things along similar
lines is that it is a pretty basic human
capacity and it's it plays a very
important role in learning in particular
and so I think the one version of that
is very obvious because it's so familiar
to our everyday experience but then once
you dig into it it gets a little bit
more peculiar so so one thing to think
about is that I think it's very
straightforward why there would be some
sort of adaptive benefit for humans to
be good predictors for example right if
we could predict what's going to happen
that's clearly very beneficial we can
anticipate our circumstances we're going
to know what's going to happen if we
intervene to bring something about and
so on
um but explanation is different from
merely predicting
um explanations are typically backwards
looking so we observe something that's
already happened and then we wonder why
did that happen and we try to figure out
what happened in the past so it's maybe
not super obvious why it is that we
would have this practice of trying to
explain things and of wanting things
with a particular type of explanatory
structure if the thing that's actually
useful for us is just to be able to
predict and so what I've argued is that
actually we can make sense of why
explanations have some of the capacities
they do some of the characteristics they
do rather
in this backwards looking sense where
the thought is that our explanatory
practices and looking for explanations
actually helps us construct the sorts of
intuitive theories about the world that
are going to help us predict down the
line okay
um so to give you here's here's one
example uh something along these lines
so one of the phenomena that I'm really
interested in is that we seem to learn
better by explaining to ourselves or to
other people right which is a little bit
puzzling because when you explain to
yourself or to somebody else you don't
get new information right if you give me
an explanation you've given me something
new but if I'm explaining to myself I'm
just rearranging the pieces that are
already in my head
um so what's going on there so we
construct all of these lab studies where
we compare people who are learning some
tasks by explaining to themselves versus
doing something else like thinking aloud
or describing some sort of control or
comparison task and we find find that
the people who are explaining to
themselves actually learn better they
learn certain kinds of regularities in
the environment better than those who
don't so for example they're more likely
to identify subtle patterns that
differentiate two categories that
they're trying to learn to differentiate
so sorry can you can we elaborate on
what the two choices are like one person
is is seeking an explanation and the
other person is doing what that's right
so it varies across across experiments
because there's no perfect control
condition but to make this all more
concrete suppose you come into the lab
and you're in one of these experiments
your task is going to be to learn to
categorize new types of robots Okay I'm
going to show you eight examples of
robots four belong to glorp the glorp
category and four belongs the drunt
category so you're going to have four
labeled examples of each type of robot
and you're going to study these in order
to figure out how to differentiate
corpse endurance because I'm going to
show you some new robots later and
you're gonna have to tell me if they're
a glorps or address so I'm looking for
the pattern exactly so everybody in our
task is basically trying to find what
what the pattern is a me stimulate that
will allow them to generalize to new
case so here's what we manipulate half
the participants as they're studying the
glorps and the drunts get asked an
explanation question so we ask them like
why do you think this one's a glorb why
do you think this one said rent and they
try to come up with an explanation and
we don't tell them if they're right or
wrong so they're not getting any
feedback but they're engaged in
explanation seeking and we compare what
they learn to participants in a
controlled condition and the control
condition we varied across studies it
could be describe this Corp describe the
strength so they're being forced to use
language they're being forced to pay
attention to the task we could ask them
to think aloud just tell us what you're
thinking as you are studying this
corporate rent or we could give them no
instructions at all but give them an
opportunity to study so that everybody
basically has the same task has the same
data now we we design the stimuli these
corpse and drugs or whatever whatever
we're studying that particular
experiment so that there's some
relatively subtle pattern that you might
discover that differentiates the corpse
in dress there's other things going on
too but maybe it only accounts for half
of the corpse and friends or 75 of the
Globes and drones the only thing that
accounts for you know that all that only
the trends have versus all only the
corpse is this sort of subtle pattern
and what we find is that the
participants who are prompted to explain
are significantly more likely than those
in these alternative conditions to
discover that so so what's going on
there well it looks like by virtue of
the fact that they were trying to
explain they learned something real
about the structure of these stimuli and
they learned it part of what I think
better sorry they learned it faster and
better than they would have otherwise
that's right that's right that's right
and so it seems like there's something
about human explanation seeking that at
least for particular kinds of structure
in the world might be especially good at
making us formulate useful hypotheses
test them in effective ways and come up
with sort of a good way of
characterizing some real generalization
and this is a place where you might
think Simplicity is beneficial even if
the world is not simple by virtue of
trying to find a simple pattern we might
sort of look harder and try harder and
discover whatever structure is actually
there even if the structure that's there
is not itself simple and in the clerks
and rents are the patterns that they
will ultimately find ones that they can
interpret kind of functionally for the
robot their little robots so they have a
pre-existing idea of what robots might
do or is it just like this one has
stripes and this one has spots we've
done the studies both ways so sometimes
they're totally arbitrary features that
don't seem very meaningful so for
example some of them have feet that are
pointy at the bottom and some of them
have feet that are flat at the bottom
um and you can come up with reasons why
that might matter for being a
corporation but I you know don't know a
lot about corpse and rent so probably
not
um in other versions We actually give
people more information that would allow
them to make that be meaningful so for
example we tell them that some of these
are indoor robots and some of them are
outdoor robots and now all of a sudden
you can kind of come up with some
reasons why foot shape might matter
maybe they'll you know scratch the
wooden floor if they have pointy feet in
but that makes sense on a a different
type of material
um and what we find there is that
explaining makes you more likely to
discover the sort of simple pattern that
accounts for all cases either way but
that when you have this Rich background
information
you use that more when you're trying to
explain and I think that makes sense
when we think about explanation in
everyday cases a lot of what explaining
looks like is trying to make sense of
new observations in the context of what
we already know we're trying to sort of
like fit it in to what our existing
beliefs and intuitive theories of the
world are and so when we prompt people
to explain we see them doing that more
they're sort of trying to come up with a
story about like why pointavers this
flat feet would make sense given that
their indoor versus robots I mean maybe
this is a crazy over generalization so
correct me if I'm wrong but it seems
that over and over again we see examples
where we have an idea of what acting in
a perfectly rational way would be and
human beings come close to it but not
really because they're doing something
completely different than being rational
for other completely other reasons but
nevertheless the reasons have led them
to sort of mimic rationality in some
kind of way yeah no I don't think that's
a never generalization at all I think
that's
that's a really interesting way to think
about this in this particular case one
thing that I've come to think is that
there might be a story about why it's
rational to prefer simpler explanations
for example or explanations of other
kinds of structures but it's not the one
that we might have thought so I think
the the intuitive idea is the idea that
I think um Newton advocated he has this
lovely quote in the precipia which is
something like um you know he said he
says we should basically prefer simpler
explanations because nature affects not
the pump of Superfluous causes right so
so the thought is something like if
nature itself is simple then we should
prefer simpler explanations because
those simple explanations are more
likely to accurately reflect nature
right and so that would give you one
reason why preferring simple
explanations would be rational and I'm
I'm skeptical of that one I'm really
skeptical of that
um but I think what our data might
suggest is that having the practice of
preferring simpler explanations might
lead you to learn about your environment
and look for particular types of
structure in your environment in a way
that might have the positive Downstream
consequence of leading you to discover
the structure that's actually there and
so it's almost more like a
methodological strategy to get you to
the right place but without the
assumption that the world is itself
simple right it's rather that having
humans be sort of picky about
explanations is going to be something
that motivates us to go out there and
figure out what's really going on
because the world is a weird mixture of
simple and complex right and we as a
psychologist I'm going to say more
complex than simple but yes
we have to work hard to find the
Simplicity I guess is the point I'm
trying to make and and we do like like
like you just said
um I guess I didn't want to let go of
the Intriguing thing you said about
explanations being mostly Looking
Backward in time rather than predictive
in some sense uh I mean it makes me
think of mystery novels we love mystery
novels I love mysteries uh and mostly
the detective is trying to come up with
an explanation for something that
happened in the past without necessarily
helping us predict the future on the
basis of that but can we conceptualize
it as part of a larger strategy that if
we know why all these murders are
committed that will help us in the
future or is there something else going
on I think there might be two things
going on so I think sometimes we care
about the backwards looking part because
we want to hold people causally or
morally responsible right and there it
seems like that judgment is really
playing almost more of a social role in
how we regulate other people and
interact with other people so that's
that's important but I think also the
practice of uh explaining why particular
events occurred is going to be part of
what allows us to construct a causal
model of that domain or just more
generally sort of a theory of that
domain and then it's the theory of that
domain that will allow us to predict
things in the future right so you know
to give a toy example you might Imagine
That by virtue of trying to figure out a
particular uh murder in this detective
story and so on
um somebody comes to learn something
about human motivations that they didn't
appreciate before they come to learn
something about how particular poisons
work and how you can mask their effects
that they didn't know before right and
so they come to learn all of this
particular stuff and that actually might
be useful in the next case you know
maybe not not narrowly for preventing
another murder
but but it is contributing to your
repository of knowledge about the world
yeah in ways that is going to be useful
in the future yeah I guess I'm actually
yeah I'm interested in this because I
don't know why uh the mystery genre I
mean in some sense almost all genres or
subsets of mysteries right like things
happen we don't know why we want to fix
them and it's a very it has a very
powerful hold on us psychologically and
I'm willing to buy that it stems from
the same impulse as the impulse to uh
you know understand and predict the
world going forward maybe that is it or
maybe there's extra ingredients being
fed yeah I think that's right I love
this example the case I've thought about
a little bit more is something like
riddles right we find riddles extremely
satisfying
um we're very curious about the answer
to one of those are very satisfied when
we get the answer to a riddle but it's
hard to make the case that riddles play
a fundamental role in human learning
right it sort of seems like it's the
it's the candy of the system
um and I think the the mystery novels
might have some of the same
characteristics right they they mimic
some of these cases where we really are
prompted to find an explanation where
that's really Central to our ability to
learn about the environment right and so
they sort of like push all the right
buttons without necessarily giving us
the same uh adaptive consequences that
we may be see in the explanation case
um but by a virtue of that structure we
we do field run in we are very curious
we do feel very satisfied when there's a
good resolution
um another thing I don't want to let go
of is uh the relationship between
explanations and causes you know
causality is something that philosophers
debate a lot about we had Judea Pearl on
the podcast some time ago yeah it's a
whole sub field of understanding causal
influences on things uh is it okay to
think about the search for explanation
as mostly a search for the cause for why
something happened or is there a
division between those as I'm sure you
know there's a debate about this in
philosophy and and I'd say probably in
psychology as well my own view is that a
lot of explanation is causal but not all
explanation is causal I think one of the
clearest examples of non-causible
explanation is mathematical explanation
right so you can give a an explanation
for the Pythagorean theorem and it
doesn't look like there's anything
causal going on there
um and so you know I think that raises
the question about the relationship
between the causal cases and the
non-causal cases
um are there really just fundamentally
different kinds of explanations I'm more
attracted to views that that think that
it's really very similar across these
kinds of cases that explanations in
general produce understanding that the
nature of human understanding involves
something about appreciating dependency
relationships of a particular type and
there might be multiple types of
dependency relationships causal
dependency relationships are a really
important type that characterize huge
swaths of what we care about but they're
not the only type you know things can be
kind of have a deductive or an
entailment relationship in the case of
math things could have constitutive
relationships so I think there's
actually lots of other kinds of
relationships that can support
explanations and explanatory
understanding
um but by and large the ones that I've
studied are the causal cases and I think
those are the Paradigm cases we
typically think about well it's
interesting because of course we don't
agree on what constitutes a causal case
you know and some people are going to
say well Pythagoras's Theorem is true
because of the postulates of euclidean
geometry and you know to me that's a
very different notion of the of the word
cause than the person died because they
were stabbed by their friend or whatever
I mean we're using the same word but
these are very different philosophical
Concepts I think I think that's right I
mean I think I Think It's tricky to
interpret because causally you know we
use because in in all sorts of ways and
at least I would hesitate to to say that
they're all causal
um
you know we did we did some research in
my lab that tried to narrow in on a part
of your question so we thought what's
the most minimal contrast between a
cause claim and an explanation claim
okay and so we had cases where for
example a causes b or B because a right
and so the thought is there you know
kind of as close as possible basically
but but once once an explanation talk
and one's in causal talk and we found
that these two behaved very very
similarly in terms of what sorts of
evidence people thought was relevant for
assessing whether or not the claim was
true but we did find some differences
right so these weren't identical so
here's where maybe I'll give you a
concrete case so you can get an
Intuition or how these worked so we
wanted cases where there were causal
factors where people would not
antecedently think were related at all
so one of our one of our cover stories
involved
um you had to imagine that you've gone
to work for a museum and one of your
tasks is to like tabulate lots of data
about the museum you know who visits
which exhibits and what they do and so
on and you just noticed this correlation
in all of your data there's a
correlation between having visited the
Portrait Gallery in the museum and
having made an optional donation when
you leave the museum good
so one thing we can vary now is what's
the strength of that correlation is it
just like a really weak Association or
is it like pretty much a perfect
relationship we know every single all
and only the people who went to the
Portrait Gallery mid Knoxville nation
and so on and we ask people claims like
to what extent do you agree that
visiting the Portrait Gallery caused
this person to make an optional donation
as they left the museum or why did this
person make an optional donation when
they left a museum because they visited
the Portrait Gallery right so that we
have the kind of matched causal claims
and explanation claims okay so the
stronger the statistical evidence that
there is a relationship the more people
are willing to endorse these claims but
that has a bigger effect for the causal
claim than for the explanation clip
here's here's here's the on the flip
side what we found yeah now we give some
of our participants a mechanism linking
these two things right so so if we
constructed our stimuli correctly for
what we were going for it should
hopefully not be at all obvious why
there would be a correlation here and
what might they explain that so we tell
half of our participants that actually
there's a lot of research in social
psychology showing that if you're
surrounded by watchful others like in a
portrait gallery with eyes and faces
that triggers these mechanisms where
you're concerned with your reputation
and leads you to act more socially and
so on and so you're more likely to do
something like make an optional donation
um okay so when you give people the
mechanism that makes them more likely to
accept the causal claim and more likely
to accept the explanation claim that the
reason the person for example donated
was because they were in The Portrait
Gallery but that has a bigger impact on
the explanation claim than on the
causation claim so we know yes this is
tricky yeah okay good so so that that
has a bigger impact on the claim that
they donated because they went to the
Portrait Gallery than it does on the
claim that the going to the Portrait
Gallery caused them to donate exactly
it's a very defined distinction we're
drawn here but okay good yes that's
right but I mean part of the reason I
mean we wanted to be a fine distinction
because we're really trying to drive
away Edge between these otherwise
extremely similar claims right the kind
of like bear causal claim the bear
explanation claim
um so that's just the empirical finding
but of course the I think the more
interesting question is like why right
what does this tell us about the nature
of explanation and causation and so on
um so what we think might be going on is
that this might give us some hints
towards
um what the functional rule of
explaining is for people right what do
we want our explanations to do for us
such that we'd be more satisfied when we
have say the mechanism information in
this case and what we argue in this work
is that one of the reasons why mechanism
information might be so Central to
explanation is because mechanism
information is what allows us to
generalize to new cases so suppose I now
ask you to imagine a case where uh some
of the patrons of the museum visit the
sculpture garden and you need to predict
whether or not those who visit the
sculpture garden are also more or less
likely to make an optional donation well
if you have the mechanism you have a
basis for making that prediction you
might want to know well where the
sculpture is figurative did they involve
faces if so I'm going to predict that
you're more likely to make a donation if
these were all abstract sculptures then
no you have no reason to think that
you're more likely to make a donation so
by virtue of knowing the mechanism you
are able to generalize from the original
case outside of the data that you'd
already observed by contrast if you only
have the correlation or the statistical
evidence there that tells you how strong
the relationship is in the population
that you studied already but it doesn't
give you guidance for how to generalize
from that population to a novel
population and so part of what we think
is so key about explanation is that it's
going to direct you make you look for
the sorts of things that support
generalization and this ties back to our
earlier discussion about how explanation
might support prediction right if what
explaining is making you do so is not
just find any kind of structure in your
environment but specifically the kind of
structure that's likely to be useful for
generalizing to new cases for predicting
in the future then that would make a lot
of sense it does so in other words what
what looking for a good explanation is
about is more than just finding a
pattern but finding a pattern that sort
of fits into the rest of our knowledge
of the world in such a way that it has
some implications for other things we
might say going for that's right that's
right and I think that it helps explain
why merely predicting something
accurately doesn't give us a sense of
understanding and explanatory
satisfaction you know if you had a black
box that allowed you to predict lots of
things very accurately but you had no
idea how to use it to get to new cases
um that's not going to give you what we
want in explanations even though you're
getting some predictive leverage there
it is weird because in certain corners
of modern physics I I'm bringing up
physics more than average in this uh
philos in this psychology conversation
but there's a movement because precisely
because some Modern theories of physics
invoke things we can't observe right
like the Multiverse or string theory or
whatever there's a sort of
countervailing argument that says all I
care about is making predictions for
observations uh and you know we have to
stand up for the idea that no actually I
want to know why I want to actually know
the explanation some people are are
moving away from that so uh I'd like it
I like the idea that uh it's really the
knowing why that is the goal here not
merely recognizing the existence of a
pattern that's right although I think in
the physics cases you get to a real
question which at least for me is an
open question which is what are the
limits of that right are there going to
be cases where our human mind is not
capable of understanding the why the
best we can do is is that you know
predict in some cases or rely on our
deep learning system or extremely
complicated Theory to do the predicting
for us
um so I I think that is as an account of
the psychology of explanation I think we
really do care about the why and then
thinking about what does that mean for
science I think in that case you really
come up against these cases where it
might turn out that some things are
beyond our our human capacities it's
possible but I don't think we're there
yet so I'm not worried about that like
if that comes up then I'll then be an
optimist about this so thank you I do I
do and uh I guess this has been implicit
in some of the things we said but from
the psychological angle have we learned
what counts as a good explanation I
think we all have ideas about what
counts as a good one again making
ability to predict the future fitting
into other things we think but is it
like an accepted set of criteria for
what an explanation is a good one yeah
they're sort of there's sort of two
questions and I think we have partial
answers to both one is what even counts
as an explanation right so that contrast
is really what's an explanation versus a
non-explanation and for that I think an
explanation typically generates
understanding about why what you're
asking about was the case as opposed to
some often implicit contrast right so if
I you say you know why
um why is the sky blue I might be
implicitly asking why is it blue as
opposed to another color and an
explanation has to generate
understanding about why it's blue as
opposed to another color you might very
legitimately then say what do you mean
by understanding there and we can come
back to that but I want to contrast that
with
um the question more the way you
formulated it which is more like given
that something is an explanation or
being offered as an explanation what
makes it a good explanation or a
satisfying explanation and there we know
a bunch of features that seem to play
similar so we've been talking about
Simplicity that seems to be one of them
and there seem to be a few different
Notions of simplicity so we can unpack
that further and talk about kinds of
Simplicity
um breadth seems to be another one so we
like explanations that explain
everything we invoke them to explain not
just sort of subsets of it we do being
consistent with your prior beliefs as
you've already suggested to sort of sort
of fit in with what you already know
people like explanations better that
don't make unprecedented untested
predictions right so if something
predict something that hasn't been um uh
observed that might feel a little bit
risky and we don't we don't like them
that's so much in our explanations isn't
that the opposite of what philosophy of
science is supposed to tell us that we
love the explanations that have that
make predictions that haven't been
tested yet because then we can go test
them yeah that's not what the psychology
suggests but yes it's the psychology
result here is very puzzling so this is
this is a body of work focusing on what
they call latent scope and the idea is
that
um it's thought of typically as an error
but for example if you have two diseases
that could explain a set of symptoms one
of them predicts that if we did a blood
test that we haven't yet Done Yet you'd
see an abnormal value and the other one
predicts that you'd actually see a
normal value people seem to prefer the
theory that does not make the uh
unverified prediction that may be
departs from the default even in
conditions where you statistically
control for various things so that seems
like it's maybe maybe an error although
it's perhaps an error we can understand
as an over generalization of a strategy
that makes makes sense under some
conditions sure um other cases like this
are sometimes I sometimes call them
explanatory vices as exposed to
explanatory virtues because it's not
clear that they're
um they're always rational strategies
for evaluating explanations but to give
you other examples people do prefer
explanations sometimes that involve
reductive jargon so the classic case of
this is that if you give people
explanations for psychological phenomena
that do or don't invoke totally
irrelevant neuroscience at least that
Neuroscience is irrelevant according to
experts sure you typically find that lay
people like those explanations better
with that reductive jargon
there is a similar finding it was in the
context of scientific abstracts rather
than explanations but people were were
uh seduced by irrelevant math right so
if you add some relevant math in there
maybe that makes it seem uh more
legitimate more rigorous I do that all
the time so good nice it's irrelevant
but the novice maybe can't
um people tend to like explanations that
offer a mechanism we've talked about
that already
um uh you know there's other
characteristics like this I think part
of what's challenging is that for any
one of these there's a question of how
you really Define that right like so for
example what do we mean was to say an
explanation is simpler or broader and so
on and also most of these do show some
context sensitivity and that makes it
very hard to make unqualified
generalizations so to give you an
example with respect to Simplicity that
we've been talking about uh people also
seem to have this view that very complex
phenomena might require a more complex
explanation and so even though they
generally seem to prefer simpler
explanations for a very complex
phenomenon you might actually see
something that goes a little bit the
other way where they start to think that
you know
some complexities required in the
explanation itself okay good yeah I can
see that in different contexts and I
wonder but there must be I guess
different people react to different ones
of different of these standards
differently sorry I'm not articulating
this very well but I mean maybe some
people are more in it for the Simplicity
some people are more scope some people
are more in it for the fit to existing
knowledge things like that yeah I think
that's right so I think that's an area
where we actually just don't have much
data so far there's a little bit the
data that is there does suggest that
there are there's individual variation
across people and the extent to which
for example they want the mechanistic
details and I think we all know this
from everyday life there's a people who
are just happy to oh yeah you show them
a microwave for the first time and
they're like great you know I know it's
button to push and that's it and there's
a person who really wants to understand
like well what's going on under the hood
so that's a dimension of individual
variation that's been documented in
explaining other people's behavior you
also find variation in the extent to
which people are open to their being
more complex interactions between a
person and their environment versus
tending to think that it's sort of like
a more simple straightforward
explanation just in terms of the person
I'm weirdly the person who does not want
to know uh the details sometimes like
when I'm at the dentist and they're
always like would you like to see the uh
what we're doing to your teeth and no I
have no desire whatsoever to see that
just make it work just make them healthy
I think you've also written about
some things that maybe I don't know if
they count as explanations or not but
there's the idea of an explanation as
kind of an abstract framework but
there's the strategy of telling a story
or an anecdote or a narrative and
sometimes people are gonna count that or
even prefer that in terms of being an
explanation yeah I think those cases are
fascinating part of the reason I started
to think about it was because most of my
research is really focused on the role
of explanation and learning suggesting
that explanation is important for
generalization and so on and for for
that story to work you really want
explanations to be focusing on
relatively abstract generalizable
features of a situation that's what we
tend to look for in science right we
like science we like explanations and
then both laws and things like that
um and so I was trying to reconcile that
with this this other everyday human
behavior which is that you ask someone
why they why they relate to work and
they don't give you some abstract
generalization they say like oh my gosh
you won't believe the morning I've had
right and then they'll tell you about
um you know the play-by-play leading up
to their being late to work and that
feels much more like storytelling or
narrative and so the way I think about
this now is I think there's sort of a
Continuum between these I think very
often everyday human explanations can
sort of be an intermediate Point sort of
giving you the very abstract and
realizable features of a situation
versus focusing on these concrete
particulars and I think they serve
different functions so I think the the
law-like generalizations are useful
precisely because they support
generalization to other cases they're
picking out the features of a situation
that are relatively invariant that might
support prediction to other cases and so
on I think a lot of these other things
the the concrete sensory details you
know the things that make a a piece of
fiction really compelling all of that
extra nuance and detail I think part of
what that's doing is giving you
input that allows you to do something
like a mental simulation of the
situation or put yourself in somebody's
shoes and so you understand the
situation from a particular sort of
embodied perspective and that can give
you a kind of insight about the
particulars of that situation that you
might not get from from this more
abstract perspective you know so for
example by virtue of hearing about the
play-by-play of your morning and how you
spilled your coffee and so on I'm going
to be in a better position to appreciate
how you really felt and how how it was
frustrating and what that might have led
you to to think or to feel or to say and
so on
um and so it might be partially a
peculiarity of the way human cognition
works but it's it's partially by getting
those concrete particulars that we can
engage in those kinds of mental
simulations effectively no I think it's
a fascinating Point very interesting is
it is it almost a mirror neuron
situation
oh gosh I I think I'm gonna not
speculate about mirror neurons because I
will get myself in trouble I certainly
don't think that that's I don't think
that's likely to be a necessary part of
this story you see I'm adding on
unnecessary Neuroscience to make it a
more compelling explanation
explanation
you like the idea that somehow forget
about the mirror neurons but the
embodiment of the uh explanation like
there's a set of rules abstractly okay
that's one thing if I can picture myself
in it that's another level of
appreciation of this purported
explanation right that's right that's
right I mean sometimes I think you see
this reflected in natural language and
in discussions of philosophy as well in
terms of different kinds of
understanding you know one kind of
understanding we talk about is the sort
of understanding where you say you know
I understand quantum mechanics or I
understand
um you know how to derive the
Pythagorean theorem or something like
that where it seems to be this
relatively like abstract kind of
understanding but then there's another
thing we do where we say like oh I
really understand where you're coming
from I really understand her I really
understand the character of this book or
I feel understood and all of those
Notions seem to be much more like this
sort of first personal story narrative
like case where we really can sort of
put ourselves in the position of
somebody else and so just just like I
think you know explanation storytelling
sort of span the scam and I think these
different Notions of understanding show
a similar kind of variation I like that
is it also possible that the
storytelling end of the spectrum sort of
gets a bad rap because we valorize
rationality that's interesting so I
think I think it would legitimately get
a bad rap if we used the concrete
storytelling to serve the roles that
should be served by the more General
explanation right so an example like
that might be somebody taking an
anecdote to be a good basis for a public
policy decision for example rather than
looking at data and the generalizations
that are actually available to us at
this large scale and there is some
evidence like that I mean in the context
of persuasion anecdotes and good stories
are persuasive oh yeah
um and so that those might be cases
where they legitimately get a bad rap
insofar as they are being mistaken for
strong evidence but on the other hand I
think they're playing a really important
role right so I think I think maybe what
we need to do is legitimate eyes
valuable roles for stories and for that
that mode of explanation
as long as we don't mistake it for
playing the role of giving us the
abstract generalization and maybe for
empathy more broadly I did talk to Paul
Bloom on the podcast and he made the
opposite claim he worried that people
were too quick to be empathetic and that
sort of biased them toward people like
themselves and they should try to be
more rational and I tried to say well
but yes we should the solution to that
is not to not be empathetic but to be
empathetic to a broader spectrum of
people and I'm not sure who's right
there yeah I I'm inclined to to say that
there's value to empathy there's value
to empathy in a broader range of cases
but maybe we shouldn't only rely on
empathy right that's just one of the
tools that we have for making sense of a
situation so why does it have to be
rationality or empathy or you know what
the utilitarian calculus or the kind of
empathic response maybe we should see
what each has to offer and then
integrate both of those into our overall
evaluation fair enough so how often in
this whole game do you run across the
issue of what is the explanation for the
explanation like is there a bottoming
out of these explanations anywhere
people at what point are people
satisfied to say like okay that's the
explanation I don't need to dig more
deeply I wish I knew the answer to that
question we have definitely thought
about it I can I can tell you the the
crumbs we've picked out you know in the
vicinity but but we don't have an answer
to that um so one thing that's really
interesting is that when you get a
satisfying explanation that doesn't stop
inquiry right I mean you might have
thought that you keep looking until you
get a satisfying explanation and then
once you get a satisfying explanation
like yeah you're done
um at least for kind of Rich real world
cases like
um explanations for why the dinosaurs
became extinct and things like that what
you find is that when somebody's
received a satisfying explanation
they're now more curious about follow-up
questions so it's almost like they've
found like oh there's stuff to learn
here good this is valuable this is Rich
and they keep going
um another thing that we've we have a
little bit of evidence for this is more
tenuous but I think it's plausible one
place where questioning might stop is
where you can't imagine a plausible
other way than things could be right so
in order to ask a question like why is
the sky blue it seems like on some level
you have to represent the possibility
that could have been non-glue
yes and so it could be that some of when
where things bottom out is where you
just you either either don't or can't
represent a real alternative to the way
that things are so if you can't imagine
something nothing existing instead of
something for example then you might not
be puzzled by the question of why is
there something rather than nothing it's
only once you recognize this alternative
possibility that you're able to ask the
question well why X and not y right the
Y has to be there even if it's implicit
you scooped me I was exactly next going
to ask you a entirely unfair question
which is what is your feeling about the
question why is there something rather
than nothing I mean my feeling is that
that's the kind of grammatical
construction that looks like it's
perfectly well formed but it doesn't
actually apply that the world is not the
kind of thing that necessarily has an
explanation for why it exists yeah
that's interesting I I don't know how to
think about that case except to say that
I I have a hard time knowing what the
alternative would be right and I think
that's that's part of my having my hard
time wrapping around the my head around
the question
um but um but as I said our evidence for
that is indirect I don't think I have
any great evidence to speak to this
something rather than nothing question I
mean I will say something which I think
is also sort of related to this which is
that we found variation in the cases
where people are willing to accept that
something is a mystery okay and so uh
we'll try out your intuitions here so if
I said something like why does the moon
cause the tides it's a mystery I mean
that just seems very yeah not just
because you probably not just because
you probably actually know something
about the the physics there but um like
that's the sort of thing that's not it
can't be a mystery right but if I say
something like
um why does God answer prayer and I say
this to somebody who is a Believer
believes that there is a God and God
answers prayer and so on it's a mystery
that seems much more acceptable right
and so that's that's something we find
is a reliable domain difference where
people tend to think that science
specific question sort of demand an
explanation more than religion questions
that it's more acceptable to say that
it's a mystery for the religion
questions and for the science questions
and we find variation for other things
in between
um I'm not entirely sure what to make of
this but philosophical psychology fall
somewhere between okay Natural Science
and and religion in terms of people's
willingness to
um sort of accepted some mystery claims
and so I think part of this has to do
with the perceived limits of human
comprehension that seems to be part of
the story we have some data for that but
that isn't the whole story there also
seems to be variation across these cases
and what people think we should try to
explain so some people have the sense
that some things are appropriate targets
for explanation and inquiry other things
are not appropriate targets for
explanation inquiry and that's going to
be another factor that affects I think
where explanations bottom out if you hit
a point where people no longer think
either either think it's a mystery or no
longer think it's an appropriate Target
for inquiry uh you're presumably going
to stop asking why but I wonder if I
mean how much of that is attributable to
the kinds of science questions that that
we're interested in here because uh yeah
why God doesn't answer prayers all right
that's a mystery uh why the moon causes
the tides is not but then you say oh
well because it's gravity Works in this
way but okay why does gravity work in
this way well it has something to do
with the curvature of space time okay
why is space-time good like at some
point you will bottom out and I think
that what the scientists would say is
that's just how it is there is no
further explanation but is that very
different than saying it's a mystery
um so we do find this subtle difference
in our data where it's a mystery is not
exactly the same as it's unknown okay
um so in the case of these science
questions the modal form of ignorance
that people Express is it's unknown to
me whereas for religion the modal form
of ignorance that people expresses it's
a mystery not just to me just it's a
mystery full style interesting um I
don't know how to think about those
fundamental physics cases what people
think it's sort of merely unknown merely
unknown to them it's a noble to
everybody is it is it deep down the
mystery
um you know empirically I have no data
there my my own personal sense is that
uh it's unknown but in such an
unsatisfying way right we really really
want more uh and think we probably
aren't going to get it and that might be
part of what you know when we call
something a mystery part of what we
might be saying is it's unknowable you
know we've kind of hit a hard it's a
hard limit it's not just something
that's merely unknown now but this idea
of what is satisfying to us is so
crucial and I do find myself sometimes
when people demanding to know something
big picture philosophical uh scientific
question uh I'll I'll give what I think
is the best explanation and then you say
like I'm just not satisfied with that
and I have to say well no one ever
promised you you would be satisfied with
the correct scientific explanation so I
think that that desire to be satisfied
is on the one hand crucially important
on the other hand hard to really justify
on any foundational grounds that's right
and I think that's part of what actually
that that sense of wanting something
satisfying I think is part of what
explains why explanation plays a
effective role in learning for humans
right that's part of what it's like the
motivational wing of the exploratory
explanation seeking Enterprise that we
engage in so I think it plays an
important role but I think there's gonna
clearly be cases where it it just sort
of leads as astray um you know we're
unsatisfied but there's nothing more to
more to say I mean I think I think a lot
of coincidences have that kind of
character right they sort of strike us
as things that are
um you know it just seems like there
must be something to the fact that you
know your birthday is the same as my
birthday and uh you know and then we can
do whatever makeup Arbitrage
coincidences here and at the end of the
day the story is just like well and of
course there's a causal story about like
why that's your birthday there's some
story about why this is my birthday but
there's no further fact about us both
having the same birthday that feels like
that might feel really unsatisfying
um I mean I sometimes think that certain
kinds of conspiracy beliefs or other
kinds of
um uh crazy ideas that people talk
themselves into are motivated by these
cases where it really feels like there
should be more to say about why things
happened the way they did it's really
unsatisfying to just in a lot of cases
say it was just chance there's nothing
more to say about what seems like you
know something calling out for
explanation well I I agree and I think
that it's uh again it's very hard to
articulate the degrees with which we
should accept claims like it's just a
coincidence or it's just a mystery right
like we do fight against that but
sometimes it's just right and I I don't
know how exactly to say when that's okay
yeah that's right I mean I think I think
part of it might be that we don't always
know in advance yes right A lot of it
might just it's going to be it's an
empirical question right we got it right
or wrong in a given case and there's the
error of thinking there's nothing
further to learn
um uh when in fact there is and that
seems like it's a problematic error and
then there's the error of continuing to
look and in fact there was no
explanation and that's also problematic
in so far as you're expanding cognitive
resources and so on but you might think
that we're better off being the kinds of
creatures who keep trying a little bit
more than we should that's fair under
some circumstances and the kinds of
creatures who give up too soon well you
mentioned that the religious in the
religious context uh people are more
willing to put up with mystery as a
state of explanatory uh progress but as
I recall correctly there's also some
different research you did on religious
versus non-religious explanations and
and their their connection to sort of
epistemic functions versus non-epistemic
functions like the religious religious
explanations are doing something for us
other than just giving us knowledge
about the system that's right so what we
did in that research is that we chose to
look at explanations for existential
questions things like where did the
universe come from and so on and part of
what happens after we die part of the
reason we did that is because those are
questions where you see people very
often spontaneously appealing to both
religious and non-religious sorts of
explanations and so we had people
generate all sorts of explanations and
then we had other participants code the
characteristics of all of those
explanations and some of those
characteristics were what we would call
broadly epistemic things like how much
there's evidence for that explanation to
what extent it's based on evidence
whether it's based on on logical
argumentation and so on and we also had
them evaluated for what we consider to
be non-epostomic characteristics like
does this give you comfort does this
reduce negative emotions is this a sort
of explanation that promotes moral
behavior that brings people closer
together and so on so sort of a host of
social moral and emotional kinds of
benefits
um and so there were a few interesting
results so one is just if you just on
average see what characteristics do
people think these explanations have the
scientific explanations did better than
the religious explanations on these
epistemic Dimensions like evidence and
logic
um and the religious explanation stood
better than the scientific explanations
in terms of these non-epistemic kinds of
characteristics
um but part of what I think is
interesting is that you can further
break that down by the extent to which a
given individual believes the
explanation right so uh you know on a
sort of five-point scale how strongly do
you believe this explanation
um and we replicate these results for
every level of belief so what that means
is suppose you have
um uh somebody two people who both give
a
um a given religious explanation of four
on this five-point scale even though
they're giving it the same they endorse
it equally strongly they're still going
to say that the scientific one is better
than the religious one in terms of these
epistemic dimensions and they're
religious about in the scientific in
terms of the uh non-epistemic kinds of
characteristics I would like to explain
that
I mean here's here's here's one way to
here's here's a different way to
describe it that I think is much more
intuitive and I don't have the the
figures here to point this out as I as I
talk you through this uh either with you
or with your listeners you'll have to uh
hopefully this will make sense
um one way to make sense of that pattern
of findings that I just described is
that people have different thresholds
for scientific and religious
explanations in order to be willing to
believe them at a certain level of
conflict okay for a scientific
explanation they demand a lot of
evidence
and are less demanding with respect to
the non-epostomic characteristics and
but for the religious explanations it's
the reverse they're very demanding with
respect to the non-epostemic
characteristics they have to meet a high
threshold there for them to believe it
but they're less demanding with respect
to the epistemic characteristics got it
actually that made perfect sense I think
you did a very good job of explaining
that and is this something that's
particular to religion or what is the
pull of
non-epistemic factors when it comes to
us seeking explanations like I guess to
make it more concrete how often do
people accept an explanation for
something because it would lead to good
behavior if people felt that yeah that's
a great question I mean so one important
qualification that I should make about
all of the research I've talked about
about religious explanations is that
these are predominantly Christian
participants in the United States fair
enough good point so what I say religion
I really mean that as the population
we've studied and it might be different
in other cultures and for other cultural
Traditions with that other religious
Traditions with the United States I
think that's an important qualification
but I think this is actually probably
pretty widespread
um so if you think about you know you
suppose you have to explain why you uh
uh why you forgot somebody's birthday or
something like that
um what what's going to make that a good
explanation well you have a lot of goals
in giving that explanation and some of
those goals are presumably more
epistemic I mean you want to say things
that are true you want to perhaps
instill true beliefs in the other person
but you have a lot of other goals I do
yes too you want to you want to not
think of yourself as a terrible person
you don't want the other person to think
about you as a terrible person and so I
think it's actually just very very
common in everyday explanations that
we're constantly juggling these kinds of
epistemic sorts of goals but also these
non-epostomic goals we're constantly
regulating our own emotion and other
people's emotions we're constantly
thinking about the social consequences
the moral consequences of what we
believe in other people believe I don't
think this always happens consciously
and explicitly sometimes we might
self-deceive ourselves into the most
charitable interpretation of why we
forgot somebody's birthday
um uh but that makes me think it's
actually quite widespread although I
know it's hard to put a number on this
and I don't have a number so I don't
want to I don't want to claim I have
data to support the claim I just said
but that's that's what my bet would be
if we found a good way to measure that
is it just hard being a psychologist
sometimes because you're like you're too
aware of why you're doing different
things for not always the right reasons
um yes but also that's part of what's
fun right so for me uh everyday life
provides all sorts of fodder for
thinking about the things that I like to
think about right does it how much
feedback is there does being a
psychologist affect your behavior you
know I'll tell you about the most
painful case of that which is that I I
know something about Child Development
my PhD was partially in cognitive
development I really wish I could tell
you that made me a better parent I
really really wish it did
um but but mostly I'm inclined to say no
I think it probably makes me more aware
of shortcomings I'm not sure how much
better it makes me at
um correcting those shortcomings fair
enough I could absolutely believe that I
mean certainly being a physicist does
not make me a better Billiards player or
anything anything like that so so it's
perfectly Fair the the practicalities of
the real world do get in the way but but
good because that leads me to the last
thing I wanted to ask about which was
childhood development I mean uh you
mentioned it a little bit but it seems
like we are born with this uh desire to
explain can you can we pinpoint that at
like two years old three years old four
years old whatever is there's a moment
when our explaining our explanation
seeking impulses kick in yeah so as I
mentioned we do know that basically as
soon as kids have the language to start
asking questions they do and so you
might think that that's the earliest we
can go but there's there's a couple of
very clever approaches developmental
psychologists have taken to try to take
this question earlier
um I'll tell you two of my favorites
um so one was a study that tried to
compare explanation seeking in humans
and in non-human primates and I'm pretty
sure this was a chimpanzees and so that
raises this really interesting puzzle
which is what is explanation seeking
look like and how do you measure it in a
non-verbal organism
um and so what they did which I think is
very clever is they they basically use
an exploration task so they trained the
participants in this experiment to learn
how to balance a particular Block in a
particular way and then they gave them
blocks that had internal weights that
would make them not balance you know so
they would try to balance them in the
way that you might think it would
balance it falls over what do you do the
thought is that if you spontaneously are
seeking explanations what you're going
to do is basically examine it explore it
try to figure out what's going on and so
what they found was that like quite
young toddler's engaged in this kind of
behavior and so that's a really nice
non-verbal measure of sort of
spontaneous exploration that seems to be
explanation directed another thing that
people have done is look at looking time
with infants like what do infants look
at I'm sorry dude
also sorry well it's a little bit
complicated so so mostly they did not
um but there's a really important
difference between that experience for
the Toddlers and for the primates in
that study which the toddler is
basically understood the task
immediately with very little training
whereas the primates had to have like I
can't remember what it was but dozens
and dozens and dozens of Trials to
understand that what they were supposed
to be doing was taking these blocks and
putting them somewhere and sales I'm not
sure what to make of the fact that after
that training regime they didn't
spontaneously explore because it's not
clear to me that they understood what
the task was and what was you know um
okay so I that that part of the result
I'm less confident but I think the
methods are just super clever thanks um
the um so the way people have sort of
thought about this for infants is by
looking at what infants look at right
because that's a behavior that we can
measure and what you can do is give them
two little
um sort of scenarios where one involves
something that's physically possible so
for example you try to balance a cup on
the edge of a table and it's such at the
center of mass is on the table just you
know a little bit of the cup is off the
table and so you might expect that that
will not fall
um versus one where it's you know just
barely touching the table so an adult
would expect it to fall and you can do
various kind of variations like this but
which one is the kid the child's gonna
know the infant gonna look more at and
for a lot of cases like this the infants
spend more time looking at the thing
that is something like a violation of a
principle or expectation so the fact
that they discriminate those two cases
and how long they look tells us
something about what their expectations
are about the way the world works now
does it tell us that they're explaining
this is now much more controversial but
at least some of the people who do this
research have suggested that part of
what's going on when infants observe
these cases is that they try to
construct an explanation for what they
observed so you're seeing a sort of
mechanism of explanation-based learning
in these kinds of cases and that part of
the way they form the relevant
generalizations about their expectations
in these cases is by explaining the
cases that they do observe and so it's
possible that even that looking Behavior
reflects something like the infant
looking for an explanation for this
otherwise anomalous event have you seen
these videos where someone hides behind
a blanket and the dog is looking at them
and then they pretend to disappear when
they let the blanket go and the dogs
kind of freaks out because the person
isn't there anymore I haven't seen the
videos but I can imagine them I'm not
that phenomenon permanent infants well
that's yeah and that's why I'm asking
because you know object is that does
that count is an explanation or is that
even more primitive somehow like I've
tried to decide the distinction between
that and the kid and the center of
gravity yeah I think that's right I mean
the truth is I think we don't yet know
in the infant case or or in the dog case
I'll add that into
um if they're looking longer if they're
startled I think that shows something
like an expectation does it show
something like explanation seeking
um I mean if if the dog then went and
like sniffed around where the person was
and sort of looked around I think that
starts to get a little bit more
compelling
um but what counts as a genuine
non-verbal measure of explanation
seeking it's just a really challenging
methodological question fair enough okay
I guess the final thing then is does
this maybe you already answered it
informally but do these insights help us
in thinking about how to educate
children or even educate ourselves as
grown-up adults you know like better
strategies for seeking explanations and
deploying them in the real world I think
there might be two lessons so one of
them that I should I should acknowledge
has been well recognized in the
education Community as well is that
there are benefits to explain to
yourself and to others that's one of the
reasons why peer tutoring for example is
so effective in fact sometimes in peer
tutoring context people who benefit more
are the tutors rather than
um so I think that's one thing is just
engaging an explanation seems to be
valuable that's an activity we could we
could do more of
um one version of this that I think is
very familiar is you think you
understand something until you try to
explain it to somebody else and then in
the course of doing so you realize you
don't right so if we had if we engaged
in that more spontaneously we would
catch those gaps in our own
understanding we'd be better calibrated
in what we do and don't understand so
explaining is good an educational
context good formal and informal
um the other one though is that I think
maybe we should be a little bit wary of
expecting satisfying explanations when
we look right I mean some of the time
the world just really is complicated
yeah yeah remember the times the
explanation is not beautiful
um so so while I think explanation
seeking is something we should do I
think at the same time we have to at
least be cognizant of the fact that the
explanations are not always going to be
beautiful or satisfying willing to
entertain the possibility that the
beautiful or satisfying explanation is
wrong I think that sounds very true and
very important but it calls out for a
well-formulated theory of when to stop
looking for the explanation and I think
we previously agreed that's very
interesting I wish I had that
all right maybe the physicists can
figure that out for us no I very much
doubt that I think this is your job you
and the philosophers but uh I've learned
a lot you've explained a lot and um
again it must be weird not just being a
psychologist but you're constantly
trying to explain these facts about
explanations and it all gets a little
meta so I think that uh we handled it it
does pretty well so Tanya librosa thanks
very much for being on the mindscape
podcast thanks for having me this is
[Music]
la la la la la
[Music]